[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 152.
is it 153 we did a a gift episode last
week that was unusually placed
this is unusually this is 152 by the
official numbering scheme I am thinking
nope well we're gonna have to talk to
the officials okay and we are they
um it is live stream technically it's
152. for professionals here yes nothing
nothing I'm professional about this I am
Dr Brett Weinstein this is Dr Heather
Hein these are some of our companion
animals who have no Advanced degrees
whatsoever but nonetheless we're not
going to use them as trusted sources
unless uh they are qualified to speak of
things like kibble for example or uh
they're interested in Deer and otters
yes absolutely absolutely Maddie
discovered a an intense interest in
otters this week yes our Labrador yes
it's easy to uh to want to to relate to
otters are fascinating creatures she
seemed to want to place otter and mouth
oh well yes
um I I do not have that instinct but I
can appreciate that a uh a wolf
derivative such as this might might feel
that way indeed
um all right we are going we follow
these live streams through the live q a
as you guys know you can ask questions
at darkhorsesmissions.com we're going to
try to keep it tight today
um so uh it will be relatively short uh
both episode and Q a but we will do one
so go ahead and ask your questions there
if you're watching on YouTube there's
live chat on Odyssey
you can always find me at natural
sections.substack.com as well and uh we
have a new store
darkhorsestore.org with lots of cool
products we talked about some of them in
our
um
call it a gift episode which we did last
Sunday which is uh not we did not put it
out into the audio podcast world but
it's up everywhere that we put video so
Spotify YouTube
Odyssey it does have audio but it's just
not we decided not to mime yes that I
think that was a good choice indeed I
wasn't sure at first but I I came around
I have no regrets yeah we are supported
by you our audience uh Brett had one of
his conversations with his patrons this
morning you're gonna be having another
one tomorrow as you do on the first
Saturday and Sunday of every month at my
patreon we do a month a private q a uh
once a month usually it's the last
Sunday of the month this month so as not
to do so on Christmas we're going to be
doing it on the penultimate Sunday and
actually that reminds me I meant to
start by saying is we will not be seeing
you here next week or
you won't be seeing us here next week so
the next time we're going to be here is
the 17th there will presumably be a
guest episode of Dark Horse being
released between now and then maybe even
two I don't know
um it is technically true that we will
not be seeing them next week
we might see some of them
all right it is likely that we will not
be seeing any of them here next Saturday
yes I think that's right
so if you have burning questions get
them in now uh and if you are interested
in in supporting us on our patreons we
of course are very grateful for that
especially given that YouTube
demonetized us gosh close to a year and
a half ago now and have not rethought
any of their thought on this or maybe on
anything as far as I can tell and at
both of our patreons you can access our
Discord server well where for instance
they have book clubs which is pretty
cool so uh consider going there and
um of course we have sponsors we are uh
we are very choosy about the the
companies that we will read ads for on
this podcast we do three at the top of
the hour you could tell that we are
reading sponsored content when there is
a chime at the beginning in the end and
there's a green perimeter around the
screen and uh without further Ado let us
do those three ads now
so I said that and I wasn't actually
prepared our first sponsor this week is
Ned
a CBD company that stands out in a
highly saturated CBD Market that was
started by two friends who discovered
that their hyper modern lives were
leaving them feeling empty bewildered
disconnected something about this way of
life as they say on their website just
wasn't working so they started Ned you
can buy CBD products in nearly every
coffee shop or grocery store but Ned's
Blends stand out I'm particularly fond
of their de-stress blend Ned's de-stress
blend is a one-to-one formula of CBD and
CBG made from the world's purest full
spectrum hemp and also features a
Botanical infusion of ashwagandha
a place that Brett has always wanted to
go he tells me
cardamom it's on my bucket list for sure
sure cardamom and cinnamon CBG is known
as the mother of all cannabinoids
because of how effective it is at
combating anxiety and stress by
inhibiting the reuptake of Gaba which is
the neurotransmitter responsible for
stress regulation this accommodation
leaves me feeling a bit easier with
whatever comes my way
many of the CBD companies out there
Source their help from industrial farms
in China just like with low quality
alcohol however low quality CBD can have
undesired effects that is USDA certified
organic olive Ned's full spectrum hemp
oil is extracted from USDA certified
organic Camp plants grown by independent
farmer named Jonathan in Paonia Colorado
hey Jonathan also Ned shares third-party
lab reports and information about who
Farms their products and their
extraction process on their site these
products are science-backed nature-based
solutions that offer an alternative to
prescription and over-the-counter drugs
they're chock full of Premium CBD and a
full spectrum of active cannabinoids
terpenes flavonoids and trichomes Ned's
full spectrum hemp oil nourishes the
body's endocannabinoid system to offer
functional support for stress sleep
inflammation and balance and we just
received in the mail yesterday and I
haven't tried it yet what looks like an
amazing
chai blend of sort of a sleep sleepy
time blend that they've got that as well
ashwagandha I believe reishi
um
various spices and and oh magnesium so
it looks it looks yummy and I have not
tried it yet but I I suspect that that
will be amazing too so just another new
Ned product if you'd like to give Ned a
try Dark Horse listeners get 15 off Ned
products with code Darkhorse visit
helloned.com Darkhorse to get access
that's h-e-l-l-o that's how you spell
hello that's
h-e-l-l-o-n-e-d.com slash Dark Horse to
get 15 off thank you Dad for sponsoring
the show and offering our listeners a
natural remedy for some of life's most
common health issues yeah but that
raises a question sure it does what is
the stepmother of all cannabinoids
um why not the stepfather I was gonna
get there but I've the stepmother is um
uh more dangerous as lore would have it
am I right yeah I'm not sure that that's
true
yeah it could be good all right I would
take that as a hypothesis sure yeah at
least it's a starting point yep
uh second amazing sponsor this week ours
could change up the order of the orphans
in the sentence you know that can work
so there are better senses sometimes
buried within a sentence right in front
of you there are sometimes I don't think
that was it though our second amazing
sponsor this week is Vivo Barefoot she
was made for feet regular listeners are
well familiar with Vivo by now but if
you're not you're in for a treat
seriously try these shoes most shoes are
made for someone's idea of what feet
should be
vivos excuse me
excuse me vivos however are made by
people who actually know feet
someone put ice in my water
I'm doing great practical jokers no
doubt yes also known as our sun
um here at Dark Horse we love vivos they
are Beyond comfortable the tactile
feedback from the surfaces you're
walking on is amazing and they cause no
pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions they're really fantastic
our feet and yours are the products of
millions of years of evolution humans
evolve to walk move and run Barefoot but
modern shoes that are overly cushioned
and strangely shaped have negatively
impacted foot function and are
contributing to a Health crisis one in
which people move less than they might
in part because they're
shoes make their feet hurt
Vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by 60
in a matter of months just by walking
around in them the number of people
wearing Vivo barefoots is growing once
people start wearing these shoes they
don't seem to stop
Vivo Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
in everyday wear they're a certified B
Corp pioneering regenerative business
principles and their Footwear is
produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials with the
aim to protect the natural world so you
can run wild on it
in it no on it
it says on it but I feel like in it is
better no no it's definitely on you run
wild in a place I know but with these
shoes you're on it oh okay
go to Vivo barefoot.com Dark Horse to
get an exclusive offer of 20 off
additionally all new customers get 100
day free trial so you can see if you
love these shoes as much as we do that's
Vivo
b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com slash Dark Horse
yeah so we're gonna run wild peanuts
that would be Middle Earth shoes totally
different thing they're a little hobbity
it's a fair point yeah all right our
final sponsor today is public goods
public goods is a One-Stop shop for
everyday essentials their ingredients
are carefully sourced high quality and
affordable you can simplify your life by
getting your Necessities at public goods
public goods has coffee and tea grains
and oils like Olive and avocado they
have spices and extracts vinegars and
hot sauces dishware and glassware they
have everything you need to make a meal
including the materials to serve it on
and that's not all
they've got stationary and laundry
detergent Castile soap trash bags they
even sell plants public goods searches
the globe to find clean healthy
eco-friendly Innovative products public
goods cares about health and
sustainability their products are free
of harmful ingredients and additives and
the ingredients are ethically sourced
rather than buying from a bunch of
single product Brands public goods
members can buy all of their premium
Essentials in one place with one
beautiful simple streamlined aesthetic
and their subscription service is
efficient and simple and easy to use
public goods members can buy all their
premium Essentials in one place it
really is an everything store for Dark
Horse listeners we have the following
offer receive 15 off your first public
goods order no minimum purchase
they are so confident that you will
absolutely love their products and come
back again and again that they are
giving you 15 to spend on your first
purchase go to publicgoods.com
Darkhorse or use the code darkhorset
checkout that is
p-u-b-l-i-c-g-o-o-d-s.com forward slash
Darkhorse to receive 15 off your first
order
[Music]
all right some things happened this week
wow so many things yeah I've I've got uh
oh God it's gonna keep happening to me
I've got a few things to add in but
you've got two main topics that you want
to spend our time this week talking
about and uh why don't you begin yeah
and in some sense I'm not sure it's two
topics there is an overarching topic
that is very much in Motion in large
measure
I think demonstrating the principle that
we have advanced here that zero is a
special number which is to say
interesting things are afoot with
respect to
I I don't know whether I should say Free
Speech because free speech is narrowly a
First Amendment issue and I believe the
issue that is actually in play is free
expression of ideas which is protected
by our Free Speech rights here in the US
our first amendment but nonetheless
whichever way you put it free expression
is something that is now in motion that
is to say we are in in motion from an
environment that existed a month ago to
some new environment hopefully that will
be very different as a result of the
fact that Elon Musk has purchased
Twitter which has put it under his
control and is uh changing its policy
and the reason that that matters so much
Twitter is a relatively small compared
to other social media sites
like Facebook but it is a place where
influential people have conversations
and to the extent that it is not open to
all perspectives that leaves us in a
realm where there is nowhere to go to
have those conversations broadly and to
the extent that he opens it up and
stabilizes it in some form or it is
hospitable to these conversations it
then changes the environment for all the
rest of those platforms because after
all who is going to go to Facebook or
Instagram if you can only have an adult
conversation about serious stuff on
Twitter right those places are going to
look ridiculous and that's a phrase that
no one expected to happen right yes no
not something you could have predicted
but you know that actually demonstrates
another principle that we talk about
welcome to complex systems you couldn't
have predicted this
but we do find a lot of influential
people on Twitter
um uh attempting to have conversations
and you and I know as well as anyone
that those conversations had been
heavily influenced and not for the
better by a moderation policy or a
something that masquerades as a
moderation policy
which has been uh not even arbitrary
just has simply been so partisan that it
has created a kind of a Disneyland
environment inside of Twitter which is
not to anyone's benefit and that raises
the other thing which happened only
yesterday on Twitter I don't know how
much you followed it but Twitter
released through Matt taibi
um the first an installment of uh
what would it be self expose Revelations
about what took place inside of Twitter
that resulted in Twitter
uh obscuring the hunter Biden laptop
story and suspending the New York Post
which had published the story
because it said that the story was the
result that effectively the laptop was
some kind of sophisticated
disinformation campaign by the Russians
and
um that uh therefore it was not going to
be party to spreading these lies in
advance of the election now of course
the release through taibi illustrates
that they very quickly figured out
inside of Twitter that this was not
Russian disinformation that in fact the
story as far as anyone knew did not
justify uh Twitter by any established
policy preventing people from posting it
um but they did it anyway they continued
to do it and you know so anyway that is
an interesting Revelation potentially
extremely consequential because this
happened right before an election it
involved Joe Biden indirectly but it
involved Joe Biden who was implicated by
some of the things that Hunter Biden had
said said right effectively Hunter Biden
involved in Ukraine of all places
involved in energy policy in Ukraine a
place where he had no expertise making
a bunch of money seeming to indicate
that his father's influence was for sale
which of course is apparent enough to
those of us who follow politics of the
democratic party and the Republican
Party both pedal influence and it should
be extremely frightening to US citizens
that we are in the process of
potentially electing somebody who might
be peddling influence that could start a
war could start a war with Russia of all
countries a nuclear-armed nation
um so discovering that the hunter laptop
was in fact legitimate was important but
that Discovery was delayed by largely
Twitter's actions in suspending this and
Elon Musk has now revealed that through
uh one of the few remaining excellent
journalists on Earth Matt taibi which is
all very interesting
next chapter though
if you looked at today's New York Times
or Washington Post now mind you I don't
have the electronic rendering of the
paper versions of those things
um I think you need to be a subscriber
at the New York Times uh in order to see
their what they put out on paper but if
you look at this I don't have time to do
it now but we can we can always do that
we can always do that I was hoping we
could but Zach do you have the uh
screenshot of the New York Times site
that I sent you from this because we
still
I mean maybe it's because we do this at
this point that's my excuse we are
subscribers to both
um
[Music]
I sent you a screenshot from The New
York Times
and what it will show is that there is
nothing here about the major Revelations
that so what this is for those just uh
listening the New York Times site in
which the search is for Twitter
for today December 3rd is that right so
I also I believe send Zach the front
page which shows no indication and if I
search for Twitter to see if they had
wrote the story but buried it it does
not show up and this Remains the case if
you switch that uh from a relevance
search I think you're now looking at the
Washington Post but uh if you switch it
from uh a most recent search to a
relevant search it doesn't change they
apparently did not write the story about
what happened uh on Twitter yesterday
where this major news event the internal
Communications that surrounded well I
mean it was Friday night they probably
were all busy
you know there was a time when
newspapers reported news and even be it
Friday night
um you would have gotten such a story
so something funny is up right you don't
say it has been apparent you want to
show that Washington Post when the same
thing is true if we go to the Washington
Post
they didn't write the story either
I would argue that's completely
predictable sure
um
so
okay it's absent from these two major
papers you want to go to the New York
Post now
uh the New York Post which uh as you
recently uh the show me the front page
which as you recently said uh was the
outfit
easily laughed at until recently uh that
was the one that broke the uh Hunter
Biden laptops during the first place and
got itself kicked off Twitter as a
result but the New York Post
so the New York Times the headline right
here up front and actually the New York
Post is
um
so this was an opinion piece actually
this is not their front page but this is
the that's fine don't worry about it
um so in their opinion piece
uh they write that what was released on
Twitter yesterday was incomplete in that
it excluded the FBI's influence the FBI
having spread the false story that this
appeared to be Russian disinformation
which was ostensibly the basis for the
exclusion of the story from Twitter
which then the emails that were released
by taibi yesterday reveal they
immediately knew inside didn't fly and
that they had no reason to exclude this
story and yet decided to continue to do
it which matches a pattern also revealed
by mataibi yesterday where
it turned out this is surprising that
influential people on both sides of the
aisle were able to make contact inside
of Twitter and suggest that certain
tweets be moderated
but that this was heavily biased in
favor of the blue team's influenced by
virtue of the fact that the people
inside of Twitter are heavily biased in
favor of the blue team so anyway it's a
it's a it's an extremely important story
from the point of view of seeing how the
machine
um works and the fact that even today
you've got Twitter revealing this thing
and the New York Times And The
Washington Post don't feel forced to
write the story no matter how important
it is maybe especially because it's so
important all right so that's sort of
the immediate context free speech is now
revealing some another property that
we've talked about here certain stories
diagnose the system the story of Hunter
Biden's laptop diagnoses the system we
can now see what Twitter did inside we
can see what the New York Times And The
Washington Post still do with it we can
see that there is this nebulous
interface with the federal government
where the FBI is seeding information on
which a a uh a platform might
erroneously exert its influence
and it's all quite ominous and explains
in large measure how we ended up in such
a terrible
um divided situation in this country all
right
in that context if we go back slightly
farther what we have is an incident
earlier in the week when Kanye West on
Alex Jones program on Infowars
showed up after I guess we should go
back even further he showed up initially
with Nick Fuentes a very troubling
character uh white nationalists
certainly by implication if not by his
own admission
showed up on Tim Poole's podcast and uh
Tim Poole pushed back on some of the uh
absurd things that that West said about
Jews and West stormed out after
something like 15 minutes
so after that incident happened he then
shows up on uh Infowars now the
important thing here is that Alex Jones
has been thrown off of Twitter and has
not been brought back
um so Infowars lives on presumably its
own site
they had an interview with Kanye West in
person Nick Fuentes who's traveling with
Kanye West uh is there as well
and um Alex Jones in this context is the
voice of reason now
I barely followed this I was I was uh
let me just say that one of the things
that this situation
reminds me of is that we are living in
an era that celebrates the mentally ill
that puts them front and center and
either uh
and either admires them and tells them
how amazing they are and their delusions
or leaves them open for the mockery that
will surely come
and it's disrespectful it's meme it's
dangerous it's bad for the individuals
for sure but it's dangerous for society
and I know that's not the main place
that you're going here but my
overwhelming sense and I you know
I'm sort of I'm experiencing sadness as
an emotion this week for for other
reasons but I so maybe I'm just more
prone to be seeing to be feeling sad
about this but my overwhelming sense of
this and of some of the
of some of the the children who are
claiming they are trans and being you
know just manipulated and and and and
and destroyed by overwhelming sense at
the moment is not
anger or surprise or any of the number
of things that a person could feel it's
it's just sadness like I don't I really
know almost nothing about Kanye West but
I isn't there anyone out there who loves
them enough to keep him
to protect him from himself honestly
um so look this is one of the places
that we need to go here now I don't know
if what we're seeing is the result of
mental illness that's certainly a
plausible way to connect these dots
um
I have to say the greater tragedy is
what is being done to us by the
elimination of our ability to have a
rational conversation about any of this
where should you manage to create a
rational conversation it is immediately
dismissed as right-wing or something
like that right so the problem is we
have to have the conversation about how
to treat each other well how to be
Nations how to exist as whatever the
West is not exactly a nation right but
it is clearly in some sense an emergent
culture that has to defend itself we've
got to be able to have a conversation
about how you do that and instead people
have gained every system of conversation
so that none of those things can take
place so that if you succeed then you
are dismissed if you fail then it is
considered evidence that it wasn't
possible to begin with right the whole
thing the conversation environment has
been thoroughly rigged and so let me
just finish
describing what took place Kanye West
shows up I think without explanation on
uh Alex Jones program
wearing it's not even a face mask
it is something that covers his entire
face including his eyes presumably he
can see through the material but it's a
very bizarre thing for him to do
especially in light of the fact that it
I think clearly was him any voice
analysis should be able to tell you if
it wasn't
um and so anyway he shows up somehow
disguising himself
a hand on a Bible sitting on the table
in front of him and of course he says
all kinds of preposterous things which
Jones attempts to back him into some
form of reasonability and he's having
none of it so he definitely says that uh
you know he thinks all human beings
bring redeeming things to the table you
know including Hitler okay well you know
no doubt one could come up with some
pedantic defense of that statement Jones
pushes back and he's like no I actually
like Hitler
um so you know he's gonna say especially
Hitler he does say especially Hitler
um and anyway so he just he makes it
very plain that his perspective at least
in his current state of mind is that he
has affection for Hitler and the Nazis
and it's you know and in in his uh I
believe in his interview with Tim Poole
he said that the Holocaust didn't happen
that way or something so it's like all
the worst stuff right it's Holocaust
denial it's affection for Hitler
um and the question is what are we to
make of this and I have not done a
tremendous amount of digging on people's
arguments here but there is one in what
I looked at and I looked at enough stuff
that I don't see anywhere which I think
ought to be front and center my feeling
is on thinking about this tragic
bizarre spectacle the kind of train
wreck you can't look away from
that the real answer is that actually if
you stand in the right place it makes
maybe the strongest possible case for
free speech on our platforms uh in the
sense that the founders meant it that
even this bizarre spectacle which you
know I'm not a believer in the category
of hate speech obviously much speech is
motivated by hate but it's obviously not
a legal category it is protected by the
First Amendment like everything else
even this obvious case of hate speech
the Embrace of a genocidal Maniac that
the not only does the principle of free
speech require us to defend this but it
actually demonstrates why we must and so
I wanted to make that case just so that
it's on the table at the very least
and the way I see it is this
Kanye West is X edingly popular at least
he was last week
um I think it's been a little while
he is exceedingly popular I don't think
that could possibly be an exaggeration
even if he's lost half his audience he's
exceedingly popular in fact the thing
you point to the Pathology that has no
name where somebody becomes so famous
and so wealthy that no one can tell them
no
right the thing that uh I believe killed
Prince that killed Michael Jackson right
the idea that these people are so
elevated that they will be injected with
you know drugs that will kill them
um because basically they can have
whatever they want I will just say I was
making a broader Point than that this
wasn't about
is he too famous for anyone who loves
him to help him this was a I think a
more important and far broader point
that as a society we are embracing
mental illness and most of the people
who are having their mental illness
embraced have no Fame at all in fact
many of them have narcissistic
Tendencies and are seeking fame
and the response is not
um
I'm sorry you're going through that
let's see if we can treat that and
return you to some uh some semblance of
normalcy in the best sense of the term
but rather oh yes you are in fact a
lizard and uh we're going to make sure
that anyone who says that you're not is
roundably disciplined
no I look I think you're making an
excellent point I do think that there is
something that is almost inscribed in
the new rules
um in which we are forced to
um not dismiss uh certain kinds of
assertions as crazy even though they
transparently are and
um and that's clearly going on here but
anyway even I mean let's just
play my game here for a second he is
exceedingly popular I don't know how
many
million followers he has but
it's a very large number
he is also
got political aspirations
he's run for president once very well
you roll your eyes but
when somebody with as much reach as this
person has
decides that they want to do something
like this the idea that it is
preposterous is obviously wrong
okay and Donald Trump proves this
right Donald Trump managed to get
himself elected president
so my point is
Kanye West
is the kind of person who brings
together certain things that could
conceivably put him
in the presidency right a nuclear-armed
presidency
and so
the idea that we might take utterances
of his that are beyond the pale and
shield them thereby protecting us from
the understanding even if and I I do
think one interpretation here is that
this person is having a uh
a bipolar a manic episode that they
don't really believe these things that
we're hearing things from their you know
darkest fantasies and not their actual
understanding of the world and that
therefore it would be ungenerous for us
to imagine that this is what Kanye West
thinks I don't know I don't follow him
under normal circumstances so I don't
know how out of character this is if
he's just finally admitting things that
he believes or if these are things he
doesn't really believe and two months
from now he'll say look that wasn't
really me I don't know but what I do
know
is that anybody who would say these
things
is not fit for office
and so my point is no matter what the
meaning of this episode
it is vitally important that we be able
to see it
vitally important and to make that point
even a little bit stronger notice where
we did see it
right we saw it on Alex Jones program
who has himself been banished to The
Fringe of civilization right so the
point is you know okay we can now take
video from this channel which uh the you
know Elite world would clearly like to
disappear right but this channel is
responsible for us being able to see
something important that actually might
be at some point relevant to the
governance of the country and the fate
of the world so you know it seems to me
like it couldn't really be a stronger
case for you know what let us you know
not be snowflakes and let us not pretend
the fact that somebody has said
something terrible means that we are all
going to be persuaded of something or we
are going to be so injured I mean look
I'm Jewish I have his right as much
right to be injured by somebody denying
the Holocaust or saying Hitler was a
cool guy as anybody but you know what
it doesn't bug me I think I'm looking at
somebody who's either involved in
performance art or it's a mental illness
or it's both or I don't know what but
the point is yeah I think it's pretty
important that we all heard him say it
absolutely
um I actually think that that uh that
Segways neatly into talking a little bit
about anacrylov's newest Pace okay if if
we can yep
um so Anna kryloff regular listeners
will remember I read uh from her piece
called on the Perils of politicizing
science back in live stream 84 in June
of 2021
which was published in the Journal of
physical chemistry letters not the not a
place where you might expect a piece
called on the Perils of politicizing
science to show up
um she is herself a chemist at USC
born in the Soviet Union
and so no knows wherever she speaks
I have since had the opportunity to meet
her she's a wonderful person as
wonderful in person as in writing and
she made a speech at Duke a year ago
that is now published on Dorian Abbott's
sub stack during Abbott himself as a
geophysicist at the University of
Chicago who writes on substack uh I
haven't written it down here heterodox
stem is the name of his sub stack and he
himself ran into trouble with a with
woke culture when he co-authored an
op-ed in Newsweek summer of 2021 in
which he claimed that Dei that is
diversity Equity inclusion violates the
ethical and legal principle of equal
treatment
um quote it entails treating people as
members of a group rather than as
individuals repeating the mistake that
made possible the atrocities of the 20th
century
it requires being willing to tell an
applicant I will ignore your merits and
qualifications and deny you admission
because you belong to the wrong group
and I have defined a more important
social objective that justifies doing so
it treats persons as merely means to an
end giving Primacy to a Statistics over
the individuality of a human being
for writing that he his talk at MIT was
canceled because the mob um
made all the usual claims about being
hurt and and injured by by this kind of
argument so that's
um that's Dorian Abbott the geophysicist
at University of Chicago who has just
republished and I cry laugh speech to do
just this week and so Anna krylov's
piece uh which is called
uh just a minute once I scroll to the
top sack you can show my screen here if
you like this is just a PDF of the PSL
link to
um sub stack in the show Notes From
Russia with Love Science and ideology
then and now and again she is a born
Soviet Union uh now has been in the
United States for a very long time a
chemist at USC
um and I wanted to say that she has
organized her remarks in this piece
which I recommend you read the whole
thing into a discussion of the
atmosphere of fear and self-censorship
which is related to what you have just
been talking about the omnipresence of
ideology with examples from science the
intolerance of distinct opinions
suppression of ideas and people
censorship and news speak to use
Orwell's term and the use of social
engineering to solve real and imagined
problems and it's really easy to go to
um you know using social engineering to
the problem with using social
engineering to solve a matched problems
is a double whammy that no does not make
it a good thing it makes it even worse
but let me let me read a little bit uh
hear from her piece let's begin writes
Dr kryloff with the pervasive fear of
speaking up first some definitions
self-censorship is the refusal to
produce distribute circulate or Express
something for fear of punishment
self-censorship is different from
discretion when I choose not to talk
about my views on religion at the dinner
table in order not to upset my
mother-in-law that is discretion
but when I choose not to say in a
faculty meeting that considering only
diversity candidates for faculty search
is discriminatory because I am afraid of
being ostracized or worse that is
self-censorship
the flip side of self-censorship is
compelled speech that is when people
Express opinions that are not their own
for fear of punishment again there's a
difference between telling Little White
Lies in order to please someone and
saying something you do not believe in
for fear of repercussions saying oh you
look exactly like you did 30 years ago
to your high school sweetheart is not
compelled speech compelled speech is
when your institution issues a pledge to
fight systemic racism and you are afraid
to ask is there any evidence of stomach
racism in our University
instead you stand up at the faculty
meeting and pledge to apply yourself
fully to dismantling systemic racism
we've met some of those people
self-censorship is a reaction to
oppressive environments it is a symptom
of fear it is an indicator of cancer
culture
uh and just
uh one more
a couple more things here Newspeak is
invading this again from Orwell's 1984
Newspeak is invading the English
language in a truly orwellian fashion a
few examples illustrate this
the journal Nature published a letter
calling for the replacement of the
accepted technical term quantum
Supremacy by Quantum advantage
the authors regard the English word
Supremacy as violent and equate its
usage with promoting racism and
colonialism they also warn us about the
damage inflicted by using such terms as
Conquest
professional societies including the
association for computing machinery and
tech companies including Google and IBM
joined the suit last spring I attended a
meeting on Quantum information science
it was a sad spectacle to watch grown-up
scientists stumbling trying to avoid the
offensive word about 90 percent
conformed to this idiocy so this is
important because
science has been trotted out so much in
the last almost three years right as
well we know you you know you can't
trust yourself and you know you don't
know enough to really understand what's
going on but we're going to bring out
some lab coat uh wearing scientists
um it's really hard to stay serious with
a really completely Charming epic Tabby
on your chest like that
um
apologies sorry about that just back
back to the horror oh my goodness it
makes things okay that and the fact of
excellent peaches in August helps make
things okay
um
it
we have but most of the the public who
are not scientists have been sold a bill
of goods have been assured and have
believed that
the scientists when they speak are
correct
they know what they're doing because
science because you've all heard
something about self-correcting yada
yada and hypothesis maybe and lots of
math and therefore must be true
and what we see here in an anecdote in
an in an article filled with stories
that are mostly not anecdotes but this
happens to be an anecdote is about 90 of
the scientists
at a professional Society the
association for computing Machinery
um oh no no the uh just she doesn't
specify it's a meeting on Quantum
information science about 90 of the
attendees all of whom are identified as
scientists
tied themselves in knots trying to
conform to the journal Nature's insane
conclusion that the term quantum
Supremacy is violent and Colonial okay
so if 90 of scientists will do that
for a non-issue
how can we assume that any scientist
standing up and saying follow the
science isn't long since gone if they
ever had any any ability to think
scientifically at all
you had well there's a whole bunch on
that thread that I want to follow go for
it
um
the key thing I think you make an
excellent point you're watching
scientists bend over backwards over a
trivial thing and we actually pointed to
the speech in um
Catch-22 I can't remember how long ago
but we pointed there's a point at which
the um
the great loyalty oath campaign has
gotten to a point of absurdity and I
think it's Colonel Cathcart comes into
the
um mess hall and kills it off uh by
demanding that he
give me eats without signing a loyalty
oath and then as he walks away with his
food having intimidated them into
serving him everybody's hoping that
he'll break the campaign and he says
give Everybody Eats and the great
loyalty oath campaign comes to a
crashing uh end but it requires a
benevolent dictator in the moment
doesn't it requires power and the point
is absent that the willingness of
scientists to bend over backwards over a
total non-issue and the real answer is
yeah I'm not going to do that because
it's stupid right yeah the fact that
nobody says that tells you how powerful
this is and how unlikely it is that
scientists will stand up over something
difficult right now it just so happens
that this links back to what we were
talking about that led you here and I
don't know whether we should pursue that
threat or you finish out your uh a
couple more things from we'll come back
to it though Brandeis University has a
website dedicated to Newspeak
they recommend replacing trigger Warning
by content notice
and offer Dei approved suggestions for
replacements for she doesn't provide
brandeis's recommended Replacements but
they offer Dei approved suggestions for
replacements for take a stab at it you
are killing it walk in appointment and
abusive relationship
now
I don't know what their problem with
abusive relationship is I can understand
what their problem with abusive
relationships might be but the idea that
the term abusive relationship needs to
be replaced by a Dei sanctioned term
such that you can guarantee that no one
will know what you're talking about but
I'm betting that walk-in appointment is
is offensive because some people can't
walk
my guess I don't know
that's all that's all I got so
I mean and this is what we have to do we
have to laugh at these people right we
have to laugh at these people we have to
not comply and not affirm and not say
yes sir and say you're insane and you're
laughable and come on along with me see
how foolish you were being and you know
let's talk okay
so
um a slightly longer section one more uh
excerpt here
um
her fourth theme in the piece is social
engineering to solve real and imagined
problems
writes kryloff in the USSR everything
was managed top down so again this is
where she grew up Social Engineering was
the main tool for building a supposedly
Better World let me share just one
example our institutions were obsessed
with demographics which were controlled
by quotas for example for Jewish kids it
was nearly impossible to get into top
physics or mathematics programs why
because Jews were overrepresented and
having too many Jewish faces among
mathematicians did not represent the
demographic makeup of our great nation
that doesn't add up
I learned about the existence of Jewish
quotas on my first day at University
before that I believed the official
narrative that everyone has Fair access
to education and everyone can pursue
their dreams my dream was to study
chemistry so I applied to the chemistry
department at Moscow State University I
passed the entrance exam so it was duly
admitted but then it happened that I
learned from a high school friend that
the chemistry Department had a special
track for theoretical theoretically
oriented students and that is very hard
and very Advanced I had no idea what a
theoretically oriented curriculum was
about but I signed up for it more or
less in a dare because my friend told me
that it is not suitable for girls
so Anna being a girl at the time now
woman so I am there on the first day of
classes meeting my classmates for the
first time there are about 30 kids in a
row the first surprise there are only
six girls second surprise most of the
kids were Jewish and they were in the
program because it was as close as they
could get to what they really wanted to
study math and physics it was a back
door via the less visible chemistry
program I remember telling my classmates
how excited I was about chemistry and
how I could not wait to get into a
chemistry lab in response another girl
who later became my best friend told her
story I hate chemistry I want to study
mathematics but look at me she said I am
obviously Jewish and my family name is
Jewish so I have zero chance of getting
into a physics or math department
okay
that was the USSR yeah in uh I think the
80s
um near the near the end of its range
the 80s wow yeah
um
the last words in her piece which again
was a from a speech delivered at Duke
about a year ago what can be done here
are some ideas first speak up do not
submit to bullies refuse to speak news
speak if you see that the king is naked
say the king is naked second organize
there is safety in numbers organizations
such as the academic freedom Alliance
Foundation for individual rights and
expression Foundation against
intolerance and racism and the heterodox
Academy can provide a platform for
action and protection against
repercussions do your share in defending
humanism democracy and the liberal
enlightenment
here here yeah
all right so let me return back to a
test case here go for it um
I think it is on the screenshot of the
New York Times that I sent you that you
uh showed there
um the Twitter search
the New York Times and others are
promoting a story in the aftermath of
musk's took over and uh altering of the
environment in which
hate speech has
skyrocketed on Twitter in the aftermath
is that there on that screenshot okay
so anyway here's my point
a
this is a nonsense story as far as
anybody can tell right I have been on
Twitter plenty in recent days I have not
seen any hate speech it's not showing up
and one obvious interpretation is that
the if in fact they are reporting
anything real at all that they are
reporting something like the number of
tweets which would be an easily gamed
metric and they are not reporting what
people are actually seeing it is to say
impressions of these things and those
two things are liable to have diverged
radically given what musk did with uh
certifications where a huge number of
people found themselves
able to get certification quickly and
now have access to filters that allow
them to look at the content posted by
other certified accounts so were you to
have an army of bots posting hate speech
either because they can or because the
idea is to make Twitter look like a
hellscape at the moment then the New
York Times and other such establishments
could report that hate speech has taken
off in the aftermath of this change when
in fact from the point of view of actual
users the opposite is likely happened
well I mean there are certainly a number
of people who have those those blue
checks now and they can filter but the
vast majority of people still don't but
I would say that the the bodies are
likely to be buried with regard to this
New York Times article that you're
talking about that I have not seen in
the definition of hate speech you know
what it is that they are classifying as
as hate speech is likely to be something
about which reasonable people could
disagree well that is certainly true it
is also true that all eyes are on
Twitter because xero is a special number
and therefore the amount that is resting
on them being able to kill off musk's
experiment is much greater than we would
think from a business perspective or
size of Twitter perspective but the the
real point I want to make is this
one of the things that will emerge if we
are able to have a free and open
conversation about all topics including
difficult ones is that this whole idea
the whole woke Revolution is founded on
the idea that if we can police what you
can say that that will make people
better right no way now I have advanced
a very difficult idea one that people do
not like which is that there is a
predictable reason that anti-Semitism in
particular Rises at certain moments in
history and it has to do with transfer
Frontiers which you and I describe in
our book
and the idea is look this is a matter of
economic contraction causing two things
one People's Natural tendency to break
into lineages and fight each other and
the cynical use of that instinct on
people's part uh by Elites who do not
want to be targeted the elites who may
have concentrated wealth and power in
their own pockets and hands and who are
redirecting that anger at other people
to whom we are evolutionarily biased to
be suspicious yeah
that's a challenging argument now that
argument needs to be on the table right
of course lots of people will tell you
that that argument is somehow justifying
racism or something like this they make
the naturalistic fallacy so in a world
where Petty people who know very little
are empowered to police what is allowed
to be discussed an idea like that likely
will not be discussed
now if you look at what's taking place
we are watching any Jew knows that we
are watching an immense rise in
anti-Semitism in the last
several years but in particular in the
last few months
my claim is that is a natural
consequence of something which is being
Amplified by something else and we
better pay attention to what's causing
that it's not the freedom to talk this
way that is causing people to do that
the freedom to talk that way is allowing
us to see that they are doing that which
is vitally important that we know if we
Shield ourselves from what people are
actually saying and thinking then we are
liable to be caught off guard which is
the worst possible thing that can happen
in these cases the key to understanding
what to do and preparing properly for it
is knowing that it's occurring and so
again the argument here couldn't be
stronger if you understand it at a deep
level this the fact that you are seeing
anti-Semitism means that we have to be
alert to it and we have to be able to
detect it rather than having some Nanny
decide that you're gonna you know be
emotionally harmed by hearing this and
therefore you won't be allowed to even
if you want to tune in right so
and the things that are being
disappeared
run the gamut from uh
truly horrible things that people
believed
at some points to uh things within the
range of normal for a time that is now
passed
to made up things like getting rid of
the word Supremacy in Quantum Supremacy
because apparently that's violent and
yeah
and so it's not even like I I could I
could try to steal man the idea of
um of censoring the past by saying if
you if you see that something has been
censored you know that that will have
been a very bad thing I think it's a
stupid argument but
um it's it doesn't hold up because the
variety of things that they're censoring
is so remarkable you know they're
they're trying to take out
everyone you know everyone who isn't
living in a bubble right now and most of
language and you know it's part of why I
find
um you know cry off standing up as a
scientist as an academic scientist and
saying no and no one else should be
agreeing with this particularly strong
because because she saw it and we talked
a lot in the first year or so of Dark
Horse a lot more than we have of late
about
um having noticed that many people who
grew up behind the Iron Curtain or in
the Soviet
um you know in Soviet Russia who have
been in the U.S or been in the West for
most of their adult lives or all of
their adult lives seem particularly
likely
to be able to see the stirrings and the
intimations and sometimes the very
obvious stuff that is happening with
regard to the censorship and uh and and
worse and you know why should that be
well why should it be because these are
people who can do pattern recognition
and they saw this once before and
they're seeing it now and if you think
it can't happen here you got another
thing coming
I would also point out one other thing
on the list of tools that we need in
order to navigate dangerous [ __ ] like
this
top of the list is humor yeah right and
the problem is if you think you are
going to police bad thought out of
existence by detecting it when it is
uttered and getting rid of it well what
the hell do you do with the comedy that
is necessary to ridicule bad ideas out
of existence right right that is an
essential tool and you know this goes
back actually to
the hot water that Dave Chappelle got
into a few weeks back
um for pointing out the special power of
the phrase the Jews now it was actually
I mean I think he was wrong I thought it
was funny but I don't know anything
about it he did this on uh on Saturday
Night Live and he was basically saying
that you you that there is a rule an
Unwritten rule that in fact these are
two words you can't put together the
Jews right and the point was that
there's something to discuss about the
Jews and anyway I did think it was funny
I did think it was wrong but I also
thought that but you did or you did not
I thought it was both funny and wrong I
know he has a point right I don't think
the point is the one that he made but I
also thought I mean a as you know I love
Dave Chappelle right and I love Dave
Chappelle especially on issues of race
right he's quite excellent he has a way
it's not like he doesn't have a
perspective he does but
um he also has a way of understanding
what's on the other side of that which
makes his humor just devastating yeah um
but anyway it was the invitation to a
conversation that needs to be had not a
very comfortable one but uh one that I
wish we would have rather than right try
to you know bar such things at the door
um which is only going to result in them
you know festering and then erupting in
some much more troubling way I mean you
know in fact I will point out that the
Jews who got caught off guard
in in Europe
were Jews who were telling themselves
you know what it sucks it's terrible but
it will blow over right they
underestimated the danger now how much
greater is the chance of underestimating
a danger if somebody has protected you
from hearing it being discussed right
that's a very bad idea so
um yes and in fact I remember
I remember exactly the sentiment uh at
the Fire Conference the foundation for
individual rights and education I think
is what fire stands for we want you were
invited to speak at and we went to the
Fire Conference in 2017.
uh in in Dallas and one of the higher
opposite fire I don't remember exactly
who I'm afraid
said precisely this and I don't remember
who the sort of
Yahoo white nationalist du jour was then
um so I'm not going to come up with a
name but there was someone making the
news and there was all sorts of brouhaha
about like you cannot let this man speak
and uh this this guy associated with
fire says please let him speak like the
best thing in the world for all of us
who abhorred the the ideas and tenets of
white nationalism is to let them talk
and let them you know dig their own
Graves well
let's do this right I agree with this
sentiment I've said a similar thing that
I I want to hear these people I want I
want it known what they are saying it
does not mean that what they are saying
does not catch on because people hear it
the problem is
there's this deeper layer why does it
catch on if you're not dealing with the
thing that supports racism anti-Semitism
in particular and I say in particular
because the diaspora of Jews lends
itself to being attacked when you have
an economic contraction but
the point is
there is a downside it's not that no
anti-semite or other racist is going to
persuade anybody by speaking they will
but the point is why are they vulnerable
to being persuaded that has to do with
the stuff we really should be addressing
right these things go away they go away
when times look a certain way and then
they come back when those conditions
reverse and understanding that pattern
is the key to addressing this you cannot
you cannot address it by policing speech
and so even trying is absurd and
one other thing I wanted to add the list
of terms that we are supposed to swap
out for other terms
the tell in that one is trigger warning
because trigger warning isn't actually a
bad it's one of the things that you
could borrow from the woke Revolution
say actually you know what that has a
place
right because what it does is it
reduces the downside of speech right if
I say look I mean in fact I was in this
situation I gave trigger warnings not
very regularly I didn't feel required to
give them okay but I felt morally
required sometimes for example
evolutionary biology there are cases in
the animal kingdom there are cases in
human populations there are cases in
discussing human history where we have
to talk about rape where it is an
important Force right it doesn't mean
justifying it but we got to talk about
it
if you're going to talk about it and
you're going to talk about it to a room
of women some of whom will have had this
experience
giving them a trigger warning is a
compassionate thing to do right and so
the point is trigger warning
of all of the things that the woke
revolution has asserted and promoted
right that's one of the ones I would say
actually you know what I don't like what
you've done with it I don't like your
absurd assertion about you know the fact
that somebody's guilty of something
because they didn't utter one but I do
believe that it has a place and that
place is part of protecting speech
rights right and so the whole idea well
maybe that's the problem with trigger
warning is that too many people thought
actually yeah okay too many people who
would be on the other side of that have
actually said yeah I'm going to give you
a trigger warning because it's a
reasonable thing to do that's
interesting yeah I never did
um but uh
but in a you know in a day that was
going to include three hours of sort of
interactive lecture
um
the the kinds of topics that we would be
talking about would be known in advance
so uh I I was kind of already positive
that I never uttered the words trigger
warning
um here's a trigger warning our epic
Tabby has just broken into The Liquor
Cabinet oh my goodness off screen all
right so our producer is going to go
rescue the cat and close that up
um
so uh
I do I I hadn't heard that explanation
from you for why a trigger warning might
be right might be valuable and I think
maybe maybe what it amounts to is
um
because
you didn't leave a written Trace you
know you didn't have a syllabus wherein
they could see oh this is the thing this
these are the things that we're going to
be talking about today you had to do
that in order to give them some some
indication uh and I effectively uh and I
think I think until you said it that way
I felt like I think many people who
object to the the overreach and in
constant inconsistencies and diabolical
nature of most of the diversity equity
and inclusion
um movement thought that it was babying
people right like you know no
grow up this is like you're not going to
get trigger warnings in life so I'm not
going to give you a trigger warning
either uh that said okay yes we're
talking about
um we're talking about sexual selection
evolution of sex evolution of sex roles
we're talking about all these things and
so you know you can and should expect
that difficult topics will come up
around that and if and if you don't
given what you know all of the things
that we're talking about are well then
that is on you yeah although I would say
I mean and I don't think a trigger
warning necessarily has to be called a
trigger warning and it sounds like there
was one and it was sort of global right
there are difficult topics in here they
will come up right so you know
in any case it's clearly a valid form
right it's clearly as long as it is
treated properly it is clearly a valid
form and
um it is being abused as so many things
are I mean the term woke itself uh being
an example of a valid concept that it
has been abused to the point of
foolishness yep
um so we have you can see the time yeah
we have about 20 minutes left and I know
there's uh at least one more big thing
that you want to talk about and I have
some things to add to it so okay great
um unless you had more on that tablet no
I think I think we've we've covered it
the next topic is related as people will
see
um so something came across my radar a
couple days ago and the funny thing is I
don't know the source was odd but I
chased it down and it's for real
um The Source was a publication that I
don't think I've run across called the
national desk
do you want to put that screenshot up
Zach
now let's try one
uh now this is the
well this will do this will do
we
you know what take that off let me show
first because I've got an October
article okay um that introduces this oh
great that will be better I think
um
so actually Zach you can show my screen
so this is on a site that I'd never
heard of
hackshackers.com which is one of the
organizations that is just one this is
them announcing that they've along with
two other organizations won a five
million dollar Grant from NSF from the
National Science Foundation
and what they claim to be doing I'm
going to start lower and then read um
well actually no
I'm going to start lower it says hacks
hacker hacks hackers which is the name
of the organization on his website this
is written with this strange blinking
cursor I've never seen that headline
before but there you go
uh hacks hackers the Paul g Allen School
of computer science and engineering and
partner organizations maybe it's more
than three have received a new five
million award from the National Science
foundation's convergence accelerator the
award will support phase two development
of the analysis and response toolkit for
trust art a suite of expert informed
resources that are intended to provide
guidance and encouragement to
individuals and communities as they
address contentious or difficult topics
online so before you leave this this
screen I have one more thing to read
from this
okay
um you can you can go off it for the
moment um
actually let me just read it because
I've now lost what I was going to say
um the art guide
exactly put it back out please the art
guide software tool presents for the
first time a unique framework of
possible responses for everyday
conversations around tricky topics all
informed by online information analysis
to help motivated citizens answer the
question what do I say and how do I say
it
that's it
NSF
the National Science Foundation
the
biggest source of science funding that
isn't explicitly medical or otherwise
applied and a lot of the research that
NSF funds is applied that American
scientists have access to
it's given five million dollars
to help motivated citizens answer the
question what do I say
how do I say it when confronted that's
extraordinary well it's extraordinary at
a couple different levels one it's NSF
right this is the federal government
okay so a free speech is Central here
not only in its General meaning but in
its first amendment meaning yes
second thing is five million dollars
this is very much like the uh award
given to the together trial
after they had found that uh
um Ivermectin didn't work according to
them which of course is nonsense because
their method
wouldn't allow it wasn't the proper test
well this is a this is a grant to do
research supposedly as opposed to an
award it's the magnitude I'm talking
about
five million dollars for what sounds
like a group of you know bright-eyed
young people to sit around a conference
table and spitball about what might be
said in a contentious conversation five
million bucks how would you even spend
five million bucks on this project well
now I think the screenshot that Zach
showed earlier let's see what they found
so this is a progress report they're
showing it so they've already made some
progress in here this was in October of
24th like they they have just gotten
this money like five six weeks ago and
now and now they've uh the thing has
gotten off the ground it says in
addition to the toolkit hacks and
hackers is also developing a rating
scale for Reliable Wikipedia sources
according to a job posting online that
project has already gotten off the
ground wow that's good news that five
million bucks is not being wasted
citing left-leaning sources like Vox the
New Yorker the guardian and the Boston
Globe as reliable while citing
conservative sources like Ben Shapiro
the daily wire and biologist Brett
Weinstein is unreliable
now a this is sexist
how the hell have they attacked me and
not you right that is Despicable but
let's put zude reliability I guess that
must be it but you and I agree on a lot
of stuff so I might just be like
reflecting reliable stuff but it's still
reliable
in any case this is insane it's it's
insane so I guess I mean like everything
is wrong with this right uh but just to
take the last
phrases on on the page here
conservative sources like Ben Shapiro
the daily wire isn't aren't Ben shapir
on The Daily wire very like isn't been
isn't the daily wire Ben Shapiro is
daily wire is Ben Shapiro dressed for
work okay and then in bench so casual
clothes Ben Shapiro is conservative for
sure yes and but that's
kind of one thing right and then um
let's see biologist Brett wine is it
steamer stuff no it's Stein oh it's
Stein okay so why I'll just brought
Weinstein uh is not a conservative
source and let me see it's not
unreliable not unreliable it's pretty
good I would I would argue that if you
would compare my record to any of the
sources they cite as reliable I will
beat the pants off all of them oh my God
the worst of all but yeah but anyway so
okay this is maddening yes federal
government is paying
these
uh hackers hackers hacks hackers to
generate guidance for what people should
say in difficult conversations and among
the things that they've concluded early
because you know the more secure stuff
at the foundation is that conservatives
like me and Ben Shapiro and Ben Shapiro
are in fact unreliable right so well I'm
apparently doubly so right that's
amazing but but the thing is this is
also tied into Wikipedia right if you
click through what you find it's like
you want to put up that uh
so the point is this list of reliable
sources is actually a Wikimedia list
which it declares people good and bad
behind the scenes so that this will
Cascade through the building of the
Wikipedia site on all of the topics that
are relevant so scroll down uh or hit
covid-19 and you'll get
scroll down here you will find uh yeah
go go to where you start seeing all of
the warning there be Dragon symbols
yeah there's Ben Shapiro there's Brett
Weinstein there's
yeah Daily Mail right so anyway epic
times I did an episode of Dark Horse
um in which we discussed uh with Norman
Fenton the appalling breakdown of
Wikipedia into a partisan yeah it's
actually it's worse than partisan if it
was simply partisan like the New York
Times you could roll your eyes at it but
the problem is it's still the best
encyclopedia going if you want to know
the volume of your favorite lake or you
want to know what kind you know what sex
determination in anglerfish looks like I
don't know at this point that I would
trust them on sex determination and
anything I honestly I take that one back
um the geographic distribution of
anglerfish probably they're still
reliable on yes but the point is okay
the greatest encyclopedia Encyclopedia
of all-time moonlights as a mechanism
for slandering sources who say things
inconvenient to the elite cabal uh
dressed in blue
and that is extremely dangerous right
but so okay the federal government is
influencing this organization it is
drowning them in money so that they can
have I'm sure a really nice conference
table
whatever they're doing these people are
now influencing Wikipedia which we know
to be extremely partisan and involved in
slander and the point is how many
unwitting people are going to be
influenced by the NSF which has
laundered its plan through this
organization and through Wikipedia okay
but here's here's the bright side yep
okay good
um so we got hacks hackers whoever they
are uh joining with a the school it was
a school of like computer something
something at some University presumably
um so there's got to be some some some
people who really know what science is
doing the science we presume because
they're making all the decisions about
uh reliability of sources talking about
vaccines what's the sciencing right
they're sciencing they're sciencing it
up
um and Zach if you would show my screen
Pfizer at least has our backs okay so
Pfizer has tweeted uh recently wouldn't
it be great if a few internet searches
could land you a PhD thank goodness for
real scientists so they in like a nod to
the onion or Babylon be incredible area
man now full-fledged scientist thanks to
one internet search which I don't know
kind of sounds like the hack hackers
people to me I'm guessing so hold on
come back to my screen here for a second
Zach
um because the very next screenshot I
want to show you which just is a tiny
bit back in Pfizer's feed
um no actually it's the top of their
feet as of this morning is we are proud
this is Pfizer is proud to announce
Pfizer's manufacturing division has won
the most valuable collaboration award at
the 2022 USA Reuters Pharma Awards the
Reuters Pharma Awards of course this is
a testament to all our hard-working
colleagues who continue to innovate and
grow the USA Reuters Forma Awards yeah
well gee I didn't know is that a fact
that a news agency one of the largest at
least in the U.S if not the world was in
the business of giving out Awards to
Pharma companies but I guess you live
you learn and um I did look a little bit
at uh at their site here let's uh let's
show the site here Zach this is the
Reuters events apparently does a number
of things this isn't the only one but
I'm here they're announcing the Pharma
awards for 2023
where pharma's True Value gets true
recognition and they're going to show us
the 21 character categories for their
awards they're going to include the
driving Health Equity award
okay driving health
Equity okay yeah yeah and the delivering
inclusive trials award whoa so there's
nothing in any of these about the actual
veracity of what the claims of the
pharmaceutical companies are making I
see nothing in any of these lists
nothing and just one more thing to leave
my screen yet here uh if you go to the
facts the frequently asked questions
it's not that interesting the entry
process the judges it's all garbage but
at the very bottom of every single page
can't wait to experience this together
uh no question mark can't wait to
experience this together I can says
Reuters Pharma Awards can't wait to
experience this together I can too all
right I can too so I think there are two
things that uh you have
um elided here that belong in the
discussion excellent I looked at that
tweet about uh
area man on the basis of a single search
this one uh hold on
this one
can you put it up sir
maybe
um yes this one I looked at this one and
of course uh I felt my eyes bulging and
my temperature and blood pressure both
going up simultaneously but why you've
got a PhD well that's just the thing is
you and I have two phds together uh and
we have been uh slandered and liable
um clearly by things that are uh closely
affiliated with this particular entity
and so the point is it dismissing people
who have done searches that result in
them finding information that matches
but you and I have spent hundreds of
hours discussing and explaining why we
reached the conclusions we did in
altering them when some new piece of
information came up or when we learned
that we had been wrong right
all of that counts for nothing they're
going to mock the guy who comes to a
conclusion that makes sense because of
course he doesn't have a PhD which is
credentialism in the stupidest sense but
two things yes one
I recalled in fact you can find it on
unheard's site they discuss the research
that showed
that the acceptance of the vaccines had
a U-shaped distribution that there were
two groups of people who were
particularly hesitant about the vaccines
the rejection has a U-shaped the
acceptance has a inverse ear shaped
okay yeah
depends whether the Horseshoe is
emptying luck over your door or if you
say u-shaped you just gotta all right
yeah the rejection has a U-shaped
distribution where people who have very
little education have rejected uh the
coveted vaccines and people who have
phds also have rejected them in
disproportionate numbers those are the
two educational demographics
um in which people have rejected them at
higher levels uh than among the high
school and college educated correct and
so the idea that they are going to use
the fact that area man does not have a
PhD and has searched the internet and
found something as an indication but of
course they did not get a thousand
responses that said that to their
goddamn tweet well they did they did get
a lot of quick tweets and I didn't go
through them but they tweets but they
turned off replies right they they
exactly they prevented people from
actually replying directly but they got
I'm sure they got a lot of mockery and I
I mean this is part of right but we're
not going to talk about this week why of
the thing that I alluded to earlier
about you know what what has sort of
been throwing me
um but I am I am probably the next time
we come we'll talk about a little bit
which is going to be in two weeks and
and I may post something about it in my
in Natural Selections this week but I
but I will say that one of the things
that I've really been
um
thinking about a new having given this
thought for decades
is how much everyone needs to be
encouraged to do what most people do
innately and have educated out of them
which is think scientifically
make observations see patterns figure
out what those patterns might mean
that's your hypothesis figure out if
that hypothesis that you've made is true
what else would necessarily be true
that's your prediction figure out what
would what how you could assess whether
or not that prediction that you've made
that follows necessarily from that
hypothesis is or is not true that would
be your test now people don't need to
then you know run the tests right but in
their daily lives
everyone inherently should be doing they
should be assessing the information that
comes in as opposed to having hacks
hackers tell them what to what to say I
mean like literally they put that in
their press release what do I say and
how do I say it a motivated citizen
needs to needs hack
hack hackers who are the biggest hack
jobs I've seen this week who put you as
a conservative providing misinformation
about vaccines on their list
they are the people who want to tell you
and us
what to say and and how to say it well
no we are all supposed to decide all of
us individually what to say and how to
say it and we're supposed to figure out
what to say and how to say it by
figuring out what is true and we figure
out what is true by observation and by
figuring out where people are making
sense and listening to them and engaging
with them and engaging with other people
who seem to be making sense and testing
them and prodding them and saying no I
don't agree with you why do you think
that when you don't agree with someone
and and you want and you have access to
them and you can say why do you think
that and not acquiescing and being one
of the 90 of scientists who said yeah
yeah no Quantum Supremacy for me like no
we're all supposed to be doing this as
individuals because we all have agency
and autonomy and we're just losing it
we are just losing the plot collectively
yep and you know you can just as it is
true that uh if
you okay doggy
um if Ivermectin didn't work the idea
that you would need some giant fraud
that was built to fail to prove it of
course you wouldn't if Ivermectin didn't
work you could just run a large-scale
randomized controlled trial you could
give it to people early you could give
it to them in sufficient doses you could
not hide the cap of the doses it would
just demonstrate itself not to be very
useful right yeah the fact that you find
fraud tells you something and the fact
that you and I are being people are
being told they should not pay attention
to us who are they being told they
should not pay attention to well to
biologists who say that predictive power
is the way that you will know whether
somebody knows what they're talking
about right right like how could we game
our own system either we have predictive
power or we don't right and if we don't
have predictive power then people may
listen to us and then they will discover
we don't know what we're talking about
because you fail to predict stuff maybe
I mean maybe to go full circle it's
post-modernism again it is it's like you
know what you people may have predictive
power but you must be manipulating
reality like you know that's the only
consistent thing that they could be
believing uh wherein two people who yes
have the credentials that give us the
respectability to be talking about the
things that we do because we both have
phds in biology but also are just
employing the scientific method day in
day out in front of you guys not in
front of you guys all the time to try to
figure out what is true and sometimes
what is true is surprising and sometimes
it's not sometimes it's ugly and
sometimes it's beautiful and none of
your emotional reaction to it changes
whether or not it's true or not well you
know it
I think what's actually happening is
that the uh Elites who are exerting
power to do this the rent Seekers
because of the time traveling money
printer idea
have
they think wisely decided to Blind the
rest of us and it's like yes it's a Dark
Age
but the point is oh we're going to put
blindfolds on you all right we're going
to make sure you can't see things and
what they think they've done
is they have privatized the information
that allows them to live well and make
money but they don't realize that
actually no the science scientific
system is not going to work privately
right they are in fact blinding
themselves too and they just don't
realize it and they are putting
themselves in grave danger and uh
yeah there's that happening over there
but um
but in any case I do feel like they have
cultivated a Dark Age thinking that they
were clever for doing it and uh they
have no idea you know it's it's
Sorcerer's Apprentice and it is yeah you
know they it's Sorcerer's Apprentice and
it is we got all the broom drones coming
now they do yeah they do and they just
they don't even know how to turn it off
they don't even know that they need to
turn it off because they feel you know
short-term it's giving them a positive
signal
um all right well maybe he's telling us
something
maybe he is
she speaking but um
but no this is actually working pretty
great okay that's perfect that's pretty
cheap so apologies for those just
listening you should definitely come and
just take a view of the last bit of our
show today we're in the cat gets blanket
in his mouth and
um
are we there we are there okay
all right uh yeah the animals do make
life tolerable in moments when it seems
like the conversation the official
conversation that has the imprimature of
all of the things the science the media
that everything is getting stupider and
stupider and stupider but here we go
these guys aren't
they're not getting stupid or they're
getting covered in blanket fur but
that's different all right so we will be
back in two weeks
not next week but we will also be back
in 15 minutes so that's sooner yes quite
a bit actually quite a bit sooner oh
yeah I did the math on that yeah and
um we're gonna come back you did the
math because you're not Jewish that's
not a problem even though 15 is bigger
than two
okay
um
yeah I was allowed to do really bad math
because I'm not a Jew in Soviet era
Russia okay
um ask questions at
darkhorsesmissions.com for the Q a
that's coming up shortly uh you can
always email logistical questions that
you may have that don't have to do with
questions that you want on air to
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com consider
joining our patreons uh read it on
together as Guide to the 21st century
where we did keep in a small section on
pets and uh and and I believe I think
it's still in there I'm pretty I'm
pretty sure it's done there was so much
we had to cut but where you might learn
something about what the heck is going
on on camera guarantee you whatever
remained in our book there is nothing
about pets appreciating art which I
think I am now observing for the first
time maybe he thinks the armadillo looks
delicious
okay until we see you next be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone